[Music]
we watched history being made nearly
five years ago as the fishermen and
scientists of O search did that we were
on board when a 2,000 pound shark named
Jeannie was the first great white
captured tagged and released in the
North Atlantic the nonprofit has tagged
a total of 300 sharks and completed 29
expeditions worldwide a number of which
we've been on its mission is to learn
more about the life cycle of these
predators Oh searches boat is in the
North Cove Marina in New York City this
morning as the team prepares for its
next expedition it will head to Montauk
on Long Island to focus on tagging
juvenile white sharks Chris Fischer is
founding chairman and expedition leader
at O search Chris welcome back good
morning good morning great to have you
here first before we get started I have
to ask was that you in the des paseo
video unfortunately more to come on that
this morning but first we should explain
you guys go way back so because you were
with him in 2012 oh yeah when you tagged
we loved having Jeff for you we've we've
been out a number of times and last time
we talked about the difficulty of
tagging and releasing a male shark has
it been so many females you had tagged
and released you have done that now why
is that significant well we were
inspired when Nora threw down you know
you got to go get the boys right and we
had to because it makes sense of the
females track so you tagged the females
are moving around Mary Lee showed us
where she was giving birth along with
some great work from the past from Jack
Casey and Toby Curtis and then in order
to find the mating site these animals
are sexually seven separated you need
that mature male tagged and when the
male and the female come together they
show you mating and so we struggled we
did not have the mature males and now we
have two mature males that are moving
north right now and will show us when
they come together with the females
where they're potentially - again the
importance of sharks in the ocean right
so everyone know big sharks no fish for
our grandchildren they are the balance
keepers and if they thrive the system
thrives and the point is that as much as
there's so much fear about sharks movies
books everything else the amount we know
about them is still so limited yeah
shocking you know that it was hard
to have access for the scientists
because they were so big and when we
created access by using the lift on the
ship it just exploded science forward on
multiple disciplines and we are learning
fast we are going to win this one we
have 23 sharks tagged in the North
Atlantic right now and another 25 sharks
our show and we will nail down a four
hundred million year old secret and
leverage that data for our grandchildren
and one of those sharks tagged is a
mature female named Lydia what are you
hoping to learn from her
Lydia is the only mature female that we
haven't tagged in Cape Cod or the
Nantucket region we tagged her in
Jacksonville and she's never gone to the
Cape Cod area we believe some of the
Sharks are mating in that Cape Cod area
because other big mature females are
there but what Lydia did is she went to
a small island called Sable Island in
Nova Scotia and we believe that she may
be showing us a secondary mating site
like we see off the west coast at the
Farallon Islands in Guadalupe Island
down in Mexico it's really interesting
what Lydia's doing and Mary Lee is the
shark that you tagged in 2012 lots of
people follow her on Twitter what have
we learned from her so Mary Lee we've
been tracking for five years this
September and really what we've seen is
she is totally shifting the conversation
for sharks around the whole world she's
the most famous real shark in history
and she led us to May and last May to
Long Island which led us to capturing
and tagging the young of the year white
sharks we had Jack Casey did some great
work in the 80s Toby Curtis of NOAA
recently and then Mary lien go in there
we thought maybe they're giving birth
there and we roll it up there we got
nine young of the year pups that were
just a couple years old and since that
time they have defined where they live
in the nursery the first year of their
lives between Long Island and South
Korea
we don't know that for sure we our best
guess is yes we we hear a lot more
stories it seems about shark encounters
with people Nets have been removed there
are more sharks it seems out there
there's always a lot of concern your
t-shirt says don't fear the fin don't
fear the thing what what should people
make of these stories we when you see a
shark near a beach they should be
thrilled that means there's going to be
fish for their children to eat
that means the system's returning toward
abundance you know the fear of sharks is
kind of a real primal thing we all have
but
it's an irrational fear that doesn't
statistically exist here it's more
dangerous to make toast in the morning
but you remind people not to swim
towards the sharp use some common sense
right avoid the evenings in the mornings
if the if the fish are feeding and the
porpoise are there and the seals are
there move to a different place
congressman we'll see you back on the
boat again soon appreciate it yeah
always great to have you here thank you
for having me